fresh off of calling the chargers and
steelers on sunday night football last
night locally here in los angeles my
colleague from the nfl media group and
the co-host along with bucky brooks of
the move the styx empire he is none
other than daniel jeremiah how are you
dj
i'm doing great rich a little bit of a
short night but uh
as always the chargers play entertaining
games
man that was really a blast it really
was and big ben played his head off and
um obviously so did justin herbert what
did you take out
of that sunday night football game in
person well i mean look yeah i agree
with you on all those counts i mean give
ben a lot of credit that was a
steelers team that's average and 19
points a game and found themselves down
17
late in the ballgame for him to bring
them back and and uh and get the lead it
was it was impressive what he was able
to accomplish but
that you know i thought herbert
rich when he when he does what he did
last night which is use his legs and be
decisive
um that's a whole different element that
you got to worry about as a defense and
that to me is kind of a game changer for
this offense because eckler you know
what he can do running and receiving
you're going to try and dedicate
resources to slow down keenan allen and
and mike williams and then next thing
you know oh yeah we forgot to account
for the six foot six 240 pound
quarterback who runs a 4-6
that that was a whole different element
to this offense so why why do we see
that uh last night and then in other
games like against the ravens
this year you just don't is he still
just growing is he learning is it the
offensive scheme what what what is it
that might give chargers fans an idea
that last night is is the default as
opposed to being a little up and down
all year long
well i think it was a little bit of the
plan last night you know and talked to
brandon staley after the game he
mentioned you know with pittsburgh being
without joe hayden and minka fitzpatrick
he thought they would try and dedicate
some extra resources to slow down keenan
and mike
and so that was gonna leave the middle
of the field open because they're gonna
have nobody left for justin so i think
it was a little bit game plan specific
for him to be a little more aggressive
with his legs um but there's been times
you know baltimore's is a game i think a
lot of people will point to
um where they were just kind of weren't
in rhythm
and i think this offensive line rich
who's which is completely new from from
left to right completely new
i think that that baltimore game they
got some run through pressures
and they had some issues up front i
thought they've they've really really
come on slater's been awesome all year
long really that left side has been
really good with corey linsley at center
fielder at left guard and slater that
right side after oda bushi got hurt
you've got schofield who's filled in
there who who keeps getting better is
playing a little bit better each week
and at the right tackle storm norton who
took a lot of abuse
for some of his early play
early in the season with the laga out of
the lineup and i think he's steadily
gotten better so i think that's why
you're seeing this offense kind of wake
up a little bit here one of the things i
took out of last night's sunday night
game daniel jeremiah is that the
chargers are the only team left in that
division
based on the raiders losing again and
the broncos being way too inconsistent
certainly at the quarterback position
for me the only team that can truly pump
the brakes on the chiefs are back and
thus going back to the super bowl
because the chiefs do look like that
they're back they've got their mojo the
swagger whatever you want to call it
chris jones is playing his head off
and and that may be maybe just as much
of the reason why than than mahomes
playing better um but the chargers
playing this is headed towards the
showdown man this is going to be
thursday night football late in the year
when the chiefs come to sofie right and
and and the chargers have already beaten
them they got in the back pocket the tie
break right now so that's the thing that
i'm looking for is we're focused on on
what the the patriots are now doing and
the bills stepping all over themselves
in the and the north um
the chargers are kind of that team that
could truly win this conference as well
if they play like they did last night
daniel and i think this this charger
team and it's been this way for a few
years i think they're better
when they're kind of in that hunter mode
instead of being hunted and i think you
know like they beat the chiefs early in
the year and i think everybody was kind
of uh was all over them and
then they've lost three their last four
coming into that game last night and uh
and i think they kind of became a little
more of that hunter mentality just
really really aggressive
attacking uh with what they were doing
vertically down the field
you know they didn't they didn't get the
fourth down uh deep in their own
territory which could have almost cost
them the game but i thought after a
minnesota vikings game where they were
punting on the other side of the 50 it
just kind of seemed like they were out
of their character a little bit and they
got back to being aggressive last night
and if they keep that you know i was
that was a game last night rich they
didn't have three defensive linemen they
were missing in that game and they
pulled a bunch of guys up off the
practice squad and
they kind of just scrapped and clawed
and found a way to win a game that the
chargers traditionally haven't called
these games for four years those are
types of games to get away from them and
they were able to stop that from
happening last night
daniel jeremiah right here on the rich
eisen show so
um
what did you take out of chiefs cowboys
from yesterday daniel
well i think uh
what probably a lot of people took away
is that the chief's defense is so much
better
than it was early in the season they are
starting to figure things out and chris
jones is a you know he's a legit
defensive player of the year candidate
when he's rolling and he is rolling so
that changes things
offensively i still don't think they're
totally in sync i mean this is not the
offense we've seen in years past where
boom you know it's it they put three
touchdowns on you in a heartbeat
i don't think they've totally found
their identity yet offensively which i
guess you could say is probably scary
right
um so there's still a work in progress
there
um but they do this every year rich the
defense that you see at the end of the
year is so much better than the one you
see at the beginning of the year i feel
like we fall into that trap every year
right off their defense and steve
spagnola kind of figures it out and and
uh and they get better as the year goes
along what about dallas
dj what about
you know when you're missing the pieces
that they're missing um i think you
really felted it with tyron smith um
that offensive line i think has done a
nice job of holding up and and and
making it go as best they can but now
you you take out what you're missing
with the mari cooper um you have the
offensive line issues i know one thing
i'm i'm sitting there watching the tape
this morning on the other side
and if i'm micah parsons agent
i'm saying uh yeah my client will only
be playing as an edge rusher from here
going forward because i've looked at the
numbers for what you get paid as an off
the ball linebacker versus which you get
paid as a pass rusher right and this
dude's going to be he's going to be a 15
if you let him just play full time on
the edge he's going to be 15 that guy
so he's your is he a defensive player of
the year candidate period forget about
the rookies i think he's entering into
that territory i'm telling you if they
let him play off the edge like he did in
that game
um he's gonna rack up stacks and then
now you're gonna look up at the end of
the year and he will have
you know 14 15 sacks
and you know he's going to be playing in
a lot of big games with a lot of
exposure a lot of people are going to be
paying attention to him so i don't think
that's a crazy statement daniel jeremiah
here on the rich eisen show um i'll set
you up with something that i've just
discussed
uh here uh to end the previous hour uh
dj and that is
what what could possibly be worse for
matt nagy than coming off a bye
with that egg laid and coming off the by
after justin fields had his best
performance in front of the whole
country
against the steelers and the ravens come
in
with tyler huntley
of the university of utah fame and last
minute like emergency lamar just can't
go but he took the flight start right
like the kid did probably did not he
probably had a sense of things but
didn't know maybe uh until you know
at least 24 hours before the start and
they come away with the win in chicago
what could possibly be worse what is
your sense of fields the way he's being
handled his his uh his processing and so
forth daniel well i thought you were
seeing steady improvement culminating in
what you mentioned just a real you know
bright spot here
before you come into this game um
you know that that's the encouragement
that's where you find the encouragement
the hit was weird i mean i watched that
the tape of that it didn't really see
exactly where you know how he got messed
up so bad on that one but he's taken
some big shots
um since he's been out there they've got
a lot of work to do around him now
because of the cost of acquiring him
you're you're missing some draft capital
going forward
um it's going to be challenging to try
and build around that but no i i would
say that was that was a one that matt
and egg absolutely had to have and
didn't get
um so what is that is it a scheme issue
where or or he's just
going through the rookie pains like i
was saying start him to take your lumps
and he's taking his lumps so
what is it from what you're seeing yeah
i think it's i think it's a combination
of them trying to learn him and what
makes him comfortable
um i thought early in the season they
were there was no play action in what
they were doing which is where he
functions best
and uh and getting him on the move and
play action that gets him comfortable
i thought you started to see more of
that as the season was going on that's
what i'm saying i thought they were kind
of they're trying to uh they're showing
signs of learning what makes him
comfortable and helping him in that
regard but they're also just not very
good up front they just don't have the
guy
so that's the combination platter right
is trying to put the right pieces around
him and then trying to figure out what
he what he's comfortable with and i
thought they were making some progress
uh there but man you can't make progress
when he's when he's at the local
hospital well in terms of the the fight
for uh best rookie quarterback season
uh we've thrown in the damn towel to use
the rocky phrase right now that thing's
over with mac jones have do you think
we've seen you know with zach wilson
finally we're expected to see him come
back with his injured knee and trevor
lawrence has really not
had any traction at all trey lance
hasn't even gotten out there we've seen
justin fields do you think we're going
to see any
development you know straight up arrow
pointing up out of any of these rookie
quarterbacks outside of mack jones from
this year well i'm still i'm still
hopeful for for zach that he's gonna get
a chance to get out there and play a big
chunk of you know the rest of the season
there's a lot of games left
for him to be able to grow i know you
know kind of talking to them they
thought that there was you know strides
being made there
and kind of you know the practice field
through film and and kind of what they
were seeing and and then he goes out and
gets hurt um but you know i i still
believe in that kid's ability um they
need to get him out there and keep him
healthy and and do a better job of
protecting him man i don't know when i
haven't checked in to see when becca's
coming out but it feels like he's been
gone forever he has been um yeah he has
been well there's a good reason for that
then yeah yeah he has been
he's been out since since uh the first
week of the season yeah dj the the good
news is i guess if you try and find
um some hope there in jet's land where
it's been uh it's been pretty abysmal
season rich as you're well well aware um
elijah moore michael carter they they uh
elijah vera tucker they've got some good
young pieces they just need a lot more
of them fortunately they've unlike
chicago if you're kind of forecasting
they at least they've got the ammunition
to get that done
daniel jeremiah here on the rich eisen
show so who's the best team
in the nfl right now we're entering
thanksgiving i i'm i'm i've got my
mulligan of my super bowl pick on game
day morning coming up on thursday um two
weeks ago i swapped the chiefs out for
the titans here uh i'm thinking of
staying put i'm thinking of staying put
with the bucks taking on the chiefs for
the super bowl
thinking about staying put daniel what
do you think of that idea
yeah i think i feel okay about that i
mean talk to me next week and i'll feel
terrible about it it's kind of crazy
right this year it truly is like that
daniel right but you're the guy who's
all 22. you're the scout you you can
look over the steering wheel i'm just a
knee-jerk guy
you know i'm looking at
i've been i've been uh a huge buffalo
bills proponent i don't even recognize
their team
um you know if you're watching like
right now like who
you know who would scare me if you're
going into the playoffs it probably
would be two teams in the afc that i
would be really scared about and that
would be the cults with the way they're
playing as physical as they are just
beating people up uh with jonathan
taylor and i would say that to me if you
look at all the afc
contenders the patriots defense is the
best unit
so you know
are they are they the most complete team
they're the best offense no and no
but the defense has been so dominant and
has made
all these quarterbacks look terrible
um and that's just it's just like a
classic belichick coaching job this year
i mean they are they're
putting guys in positions where they can
make plays and you're looking out there
at names of players that play on other
teams and are just average and all said
adrian phillips you know he's got a cape
on playing for the patriots and
kyle van noy goes back there and he's
right back to what he was
um it's it's pretty incredible what
belichick's been able to do yeah i mean
you could say they were the winners of
week 11. you know what i mean because
they're in first place now the patriots
they're in first place now you know the
ravens did win um but the titans lost
they could they could they could with
with another win
and the ravens lose to the browns
on sunday night football which is
possible
you put it all together
the patriots could emerge from
thanksgiving weekend leading the
conference
daniel they're right there they're right
there and
you know what's funny is uh
you know i was looking at at uh
tua's numbers the other day and i'm
comparing them to mac jones and i'm like
there's really not a whole lot of
difference between what two is doing and
what mac is doing
but man that the defense of the patriots
is just
they're shortening games they're you
know they're they're able to get short
fields they're just making it just it's
just unbelievable what they're doing on
that side of the ball and and this is
kind of a throwback it's a throwback era
right control the clock i think the
patriots run it more than anybody in the
league
and they're playing great defense and
tail is oldest time and the winner in
the nfc for week 11. daniel to me is
arizona because they got two wins um out
of
colt mccoy and not just any two wins
wins against division opponents
and on the road i might add and i know
that colt said that's my job it's my
responsibility which is a great quote
uh and that's true but he still did it
and without deandre hopkins two
and the rams were off and the cowboys
and packers both lost
you know we'll see what happens tonight
we're assuming the bucks are going to
win but other than that arizona is going
to emerge from their bye week regardless
of what happens in first place
in the conference
at nine and two no one be able to catch
them the packers would be nine and three
if they beat the rams that's a huge game
this weekend but what do you what do you
make of uh the nfc playoff picture
before i let you go on your thanksgiving
week daniel no richard you you bring up
a great point in the cardinals we're
getting ready for the stick show today
and we're we're kind of looking at all
these different teams and all these
different games and i and it's hilarious
i'm sure you're doing the same thing
like well the packers didn't play well
yeah but they don't have j or alexander
um you know steelers their defense was
terrible yeah but you don't have tj why
you trying to make this patrick the
arizona cardinals didn't have their
quarterback
you know they go out and find a way to
win games i mean that that to me is a i
don't care how bad the seahawks are you
still that's a tough place to play um
and to go up there with your backup
quarterback and win by double digits
which i think they've done now what five
or six times in a row on the road
winning by double digits
um yeah you got to stand up take notice
of what they're doing i don't know how
you'd say anybody other than them is the
team to beat the nfc right now yeah did
you see pete carroll uh start his press
conference and then leave it and then
return because he just you know
they're three and seven he said he's not
used to this and he doesn't want to get
good at it meaning explaining away a
loss like it's eating him up you could
see that and i know every coach that's
been around a long time and it isn't you
know advancing an age
always tells me that the winds don't
last as long the feeling of euphoria
doesn't last as long as the dreadfulness
of a loss you got to wonder like what
what he's thinking up there in seattle
right now well they're they're they're
the
and the most you talk about a coaching
perspective i'll tell you from a
personnel department's perspective
the only thing worse than being young
and losing a lot of ball games is being
old and losing a lot of ball games i
mean this is a roster that's going to
have to be completely turned over
they don't have a lot of draft capital
they're far away from being where they
were and you can see that frustration i
think probably sleeping in upstairs as
well as downstairs in seattle right now
it's a mess
dj thanks for the time really appreciate
it uh have a great thanksgiving let's
let's talk on the other side of it i
appreciate it happy thanksgiving to all
you guys
have a wonderful week much appreciated
that's daniel jeremiah oh dj you still
there you there dj i don't mean to let
you go but i know you like having fun
with me mr appalachian state uh does my
team have a shot saturday what do you
think uh those two edge rushers got to
dominate the game rich don't they that's
it that's that is what it is right
that's what it is they got to get home
on stroud because uh how many nfl teams
would every single one of the starting
receivers of ohio state be able to start
on right now
i'm serious
you laugh you laugh all you want but how
many how many nfl teams how many nfl
teams would start one
of the current ohio state receivers
right now in the app they would all
start one of them i would imagine at
least one
right but yeah i mean this is uh
the crazy thing is
is i said this about the lsu group with
with jefferson and chase right we said
it about the alabama group with all
their guys and now this is the next wave
and it's at ohio state and it's not it's
not a crazy statement because
um those three are as good as it gets
the thing is though
you can't make catches and you can't
make plays when your quarterback's on
his back so that's that's michigan's
hope in this one and then run the heck
out of the football right so it's a lot
of haskins and then a lot of ojabo and
aiden hutchinson and there's a shot is
what you're saying absolutely and some
of those not only getting home wrench
you gotta you gotta get a couple
turnovers with that pass rush
that's it huh
yeah come on no big deal
[Laughter]
all right daniel we'll chat uh we'll
chat on the other side thanks for the
call good news rich the good news i'll
leave you with good news yes sir thank
you you will you will i promise you this
is a lead pipe lock guarantee okay you
will do better than michigan state did
i'm just going to tell you that
but i'm telling you
you know
daniel i i i zoomed into the game day
morning meeting uh which is three
o'clock eastern time on saturday um i
was wearing a suit because i was at a
bar mitzvah but i'm a lead pipe wielding
professional and i i left what's called
the kiddush lunch uh to to zoom in um
and uh and richard isico who is the uh
producer of game day morning a michigan
state guy says are you at a bar mitzvah
i'm like no actually i'm i'm at awake
for mel tucker's 95 million dollar
contract
and i felt very good about that to the
point where i'm sharing that with the
audience right here
um but no uh okay so that that's the
that's the that's the floor that's the
floor yeah you got that you got that in
your back pocket and the ceiling is
going to the big ten championship game
that's it there we go okay
all right daniel thanks for the call
appreciate it see you boys it's daniel
jeremiah right here on the rich isis
show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here